ladies and gentlemen good morning my
name is Christian bureaus I am the
honorary president of the Columbia Club
of France I'm delighted to welcome you
all to see a Paris 2007 a very first
worldwide forum organized by the
columbia alumni association today we are
more than 600 alumni 30 different
nationalities are represented including
a large number of Americans and French
for once France and America will gather
and have a wonderful time debating
together before we begin I'd like to
tell you a bit about birth of this event
it was actually called tge try grant
event it was the name for the ID pitch
to me two and half years ago by
Christophe nuts the president of the
Columbia Club of France I'm sure not all
of you know Christophe did stand-up
christov
so kristef is totally by National
American and French he's so by cultural
that is never able to say a full
sentence either on in French or on in
English so his master at creating Franco
English neologisms as you have seen
christophe's a tall blond man with a
deliberately structured a haircut but in
spite of it artistic appearance is a man
with the exceptional determination is
the live volcano of ID's extremely
energetic and most of all fully
dedicated to Columbia University a rare
species so it did not take me long to be
convinced to be seduced by his project
and soon found myself nagging other
alums to joining they are here today
there are the people comprise our host
committee in addition to Christophe I
would like to thank every one of them
right now Constance and Dominique board
gila gosh Steve Pearce Julia Hinault
Sanjeev oh ja jean-luc Giamatti together
we come from different countries we will
present very different schools
activities interest and years of
graduation still we joined forces and
volunteers and helped make to this event
a reality and this is very important to
remember if Paris is today just today
the center of the world Colombia's world
it's not only because this is clearly
the world's finest city it's also
because the host committee the Columbia
club of France and the Department of
alumni relations in New York succeeded
in working art and well together we are
eager to promote Columbia our University
want to develop a stronger sense of
aviation towards our University on a
global scale so this is the first in a
series of
which I believe should happen
periodically throughout the world so I
challenge you to follow our lead to de
Paris three years from now maybe Hong
Kong a man real it's your turn so now I
finish by turning my attention to the
person who helped make this event truly
exceptional we had breakfast together in
New York very patiently very patiently
listen to me but he reacted very
positively so we would never have
gathered such a brilliant and
accomplished set of speakers without his
involvement and his efforts so under a
soft-spoken demeanor we have an
extremely dynamic and certainly during
president I named Lee Bollinger is here
today with another unforgettable alumna
jin-man yano Bollinger his wife ladies
and gentlemen is now my pleasure to
introduce to you and to extend my very
public gratitude to University President
Lee Bollinger